well I suppose I think the most
important thing you can do now is to
reduce your your greenhouse gas
footprint one of the things I have been
doing for more than thirty years not
primarily because of its environmental
impact what I do is is not to eat meat
and meat is why not meat production is
one of the major causes of greenhouse
gas emissions the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change the United
Nations body that puts out the big
reports its chair has said we have to
ask people to eat less meat meat produce
more animal animal livestock produces
more greenhouse gases each year than
transportation so so this is a big thing
as far as transport is concerned I try
to drive less I try to use public
transport or walk I think those things
are important obviously you know you
recycle when you can you try to use some
renewable energy if you can if your
utility allows you to buy any renewable
energy there's a variety of things but
I'm no eating eating in a way that is
not greenhouse gas intensive and
consuming less rather than more I think
of a major things today
I don't see the amount that I give which
is currently around a third of what I
earn I don't see that as a sort of
particular point to to stay with what's
happened is that I've been giving money
to organizations like Oxfam for the last
35 years and we started off with 10%
with the traditional tithe and we've
gradually worked up from there as our
income has grown and as a needs if
anything are less now that we don't have
children living with us and dependent on
so it's become easier to give more but I
don't recommend that level to everyone I
think people should start where they
comfortable with and if things go well
then they can work up to it but I
suggest in in my book the life you can
save I suggest a scale that begins at 1%
for and remains a 1% for 90 percent of
American taxpayers until they get into
the top 10 percent of American taxpayers
I think 1 percent is adequate you might
want to give more of course but I think
it's it's enough to say that people
shouldn't point the finger at you and
blame you for not doing your part
I think I think reactions are changing
too to that idea yeah I think we're
going you know the different countries
are in different stages of thinking
about ethics it often hangs together
with how religious they are and what
sort of view of human life they have in
for that reason but I think a lot of
places people are starting to think
about the idea of what is what is the
significance of species membership and
to see that as not really the crucial
thing
Americans are not actually abysmal at
giving their money away in general
they're quite good by comparison with
other nations because we have small
government and somewhat lower taxes then
so the Scandinavian nations and we tend
to have larger private philanthropy but
the problem is that it often goes to our
own community in some way so we give to
our own religious institution and and
most of it doesn't leave that religious
institution or we give to our own
college or school what I think we're
really bad at is giving to the world's
poorest the people who are not in this
country but who are desperately poor and
that's where most other nations do
substantially better than us
I think that it's a couple of things one
is that it's the individualistic ethos
it's also a fair level of in front of it
so it's also a fair level of ignorance
about the world outside the United
States I think Americans are really
quite parochial in that way many many
people who come here from Europe or
Australia or Canada will notice it that
the media focused very much on America
there's very little coverage of what
happens outside America unless you know
it's a country that we're at war at like
the Iraq or Afghanistan then you hear it
but you don't hear very much about
African countries that are not central
to our geopolitical concerns so I think
that that that's part of the problem
that people give so little to
international aid because I don't don't
actually know very much about the
problems that in that light is intended
song